[Musique]
un français de bonne mine rapporter de
son voyage en Chine mis le souvenir très
préciux sur le langage étr de ses FS
desieux il qu'un jour le il a la m d'un
interprte présent ses V à avec lesqu
vou à la porte dès qu'ilar les trin jus
TER
[Musique]
ocution
abstra VO
Tru fris surpris un seul mot traduit le
parabole le cant qui n'av pas compris
les la
[Musique]
parole notre français
palest
mais comm les mandarins
interprète explique-moi donc qu'estce
encore que ce u veut dire
l'interprète le menton et dit voilà
monsieur je vais traduire cher am au
blanc visage un grandène à nos rivag la
nature Enie fa l'étranger car voici la
saison où fleurit le ranger nos épous
mandarine sont là-bas dans la chambre
voisine excepté la femme de pingpong
elle n'a pas pu venir car elleité
docteur est venu mais il n'y a rien vu N
a jamais rien connu d'abord il estu et
puis par et puis n parl plus tout ça
c'est
superflu amis au blanc visage soit le
bienvenu oui tout cela se
dit j'espère